[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
question d'actualité sur LCP très
heureuse de vous retrouver ici en direct
de la salle des pas perdus à quelques
mètres de la salle des quatre colonnes
et de l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
nationale où vous pourrez suivre à
partir de 15 heures les questions au
Gouvernement elles sont retransmises en
direct et en intégralité sur LCP alors
elle l'a semblé et bien c'est la
question des retraites qui domine encore
cette semaine alors que la proposition
de loi du groupe liotte visant à abroger
la réforme est prévue jeudi 14ème
journée aussi de mobilisation dans la
rue contre cette réforme les oppositions
espèrent bien sûr relancer la
mobilisation alors que la majorité
souhaite de son côté tourner la page de
cette réforme contestée on va évidemment
parler de cette actualité avec Elsa
mandingava et Stéphanie Despierres qui
se trouvent salle des quatre colonnes
elles auront des députés à leur micro
nous retrouverons Marco pommier dans
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée nationale
pour le menu des questions au
Gouvernement Hélène Bonduelle se
trouvait dans la manifestations
parisiennes on revient vers vous dans un
tout petit instant Hélène et puis nous
vous ferons vivre à partir de 14h45
l'arrivée de la première ministre et des
membres du gouvernement ce sera par
l'entrée principale du palais Bourbon la
couronneur alors Hélène Bonduelle vous
êtes justement dans la manifestation
parisienne qui va partir à 14h des
Invalides est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup de
monde autour de vous est-ce qu'il y a
beaucoup de monde autour de vous Hélène
et bien en effet je suis boulevard des
Invalides c'est encore un petit peu
clairsemé le cortège ne va pas tarder à
s'élancer vous voyez carrée de tête qui
est juste derrière moi et l'endroit n'a
pas été choisi par hasard ce que vous le
savez on est à deux pas de chez vous de
l'Assemblée nationale donc là où va se
jouer sans doute le dernier épisode de
la réforme des retraites jeudi avec
cette proposition de loi des députés
Lyot et d'ailleurs les syndicats nous
avaient donné rendez-vous au pied de
l'Assemblée nationale pour leur point
presse alors évidemment ils sont
toujours mobilisés mais vous allez
l'entendre dans cette interse syndicale
il y a 200 cloches d'un côté la CFDT
avec Laurent ber ger donc c'est sans
doute l'une des dernières grandes
manifestations avant qu'il cède sa place
et bien lui est déjà dans l'après dans
les futurs négociations sur le travail
tandis que la CGT avec Sophie Binet a
dit que cette manifestation n'est pas
pliée qu'il faut toujours y croire je
vous propose de les écouter tous les
deux
alors bon le baroud d'honneur ça fait
trois mois que vous nous le dites donc
non ça n'est pas un baroud d'honneur la
PPL de jeudi elle est en course et donc
les choses vont se passer jeudi elles ne
sont pas jouées et nous appelons
solennellement Yelle Braun Pivet a
laissé l'Assemblée nationale voter ce
serait un grave de nid démocratie si
encore une fois les députés étaient
empêchés de voter le décret est publié
sur les 64 ans donc moi j'espère
beaucoup c'est pour ça qu'on est là
j'espère beaucoup que après demain le
Parlement aura enfin l'occasion de
s'exprimer sur les 64 ans qui va
bouleverser la vie des millions et des
millions de travailleurs à travailleuses
mais si ce n'était pas le cas après
demain et je mets un bémol je mets une
nuance évidemment avec ça c'était pas le
cas après demain l'ensemble des des
possibilités de faire reculer le
gouvernement seront la semaine dernière
à nous on continuera de se mobiliser sur
toutes les questions de salaires de
pouvoir d'achat de pouvoir de vivre on a
parlé du logement qui a un sujet
fondamental moi j'ai pas je fais pas un
déplacement sans qu'on me parle du
logement vous voyez et puis sur la
question des retraites bah on va voir ce
qui se passe après demain à l'Assemblée
nationale mais au-delà de ça on va pas
se raconter l'histoire moi j'aimerais
j'adorerais vous dire que on est capable
de refaire une mobilisation à 2 millions
de personnes la semaine prochaine c'est
pas vrai parce que les travailleurs et
travailleuses on peut pas leur mentir
ils sont lucides cette réforme a les
malheureusement promulguée et les
décrets 74 ans sont publiés
alors les autorités attendent entre 40
000 et 70 000 personnes ici à Paris
c'est vrai que c'est la 14e mobilisation
alors est-ce que les gens vont tout
autant se déplacer c'est vrai que c'est
un petit peu plus clairsemé et bien nous
verrons ça lorsque le cortège sera
arrivé Place d'Italie tout à l'heure
merci Hélène Bonduelle on va tout de
suite retrouver Marco pommier qui lui
est déjà dans les tribunes de l'émission
est-ce qu'on va parler retraite
aujourd'hui cet après-midi
oui Brigitte la mobilisation sociale va
s'inviter dans l'hémicycle deux
questions sur la réforme des retraites
cet après-midi à deux jours de l'examen
dans l'hémicycle de la proposition loi
du groupe yacht pour abroger le recul de
l'âge légal à 64 ans mais le sujet qui
s'impose cet après-midi c'est celui du
logement à les républicains les
socialistes le groupe Yot mais aussi le
rassemblement national reviendront sur
les annonces d'Élisabeth borne hier pour
tenter d'enrayer la crise du secteur un
plan accueilli avec beaucoup de réserves
par les professionnels du logement il
n'y a pas de mesure magique a dit la
première ministre
merci Marco on vous retrouve un petit
peu plus tard dans cette émission pour
d'autres questions au gouvernement alors
j'accueille avec moi sur ce plateau
Jean-René Cazeneuve bonjour merci d'être
avec vous avec nous vous êtes rapporteur
général du budget et député renaissance
du Gers et puis Charles de Courson
bonjour vous êtes député liberté
indépendant outre-mer et territoire
c'est le groupe liotte et vous êtes
rapporteur de cette proposition de loi
qui sera débattue jeudi dans l'hémicycle
on va en parler dans un tout petit
instant mais avancer une réaction
peut-être à la manifestation Jean-René
Cazeneuve 400 000 à 600 000 personnes
qui sont attendues aujourd'hui dans
toute la France puisqu'il y a 250
rassemblements qui sont qui sont prévus
est-ce que c'est pas l'échec du
gouvernement au bout de 14 journées de
manifestation d'avoir encore du monde
comme ça contre cette réforme
non c'est un peu le prix à payer si vous
voulez à chaque fois qu'il y a une
réforme des retraites et la dernière
réforme de retraite il y avait eu aussi
je crois 13 ou 14 épisodes de
manifestation moi je voudrais saluer
c'est manifestations parce que elles se
sont bien tenues dans leur ensemble il y
a eu assez peu de débordements dont
remercier ceux qui les ont organisé leur
représentation syndicales qu'on veillait
à ce qu'elles se fasse dans le bon ordre
ça me paraît ça me paraît très important
moi j'ai les chiffres dans le Gers
puisque la manifestation a eu lieu ce
matin il y avait deux fois moins de
monde que la dernière fois je pense
comme l'a dit Laurent Berger c'est
probablement la fin de ces
manifestations
qui ont été publiés dimanche est-ce que
ça vous ne pensez pas que ça peut
relancer la manifestation ou en tout cas
est-ce que c'est pas une provocation
je n'espère pas je crois que la
concertation a eu lieu pendant de
nombreuses semaines de nombreux mois le
projet de loi a été modifié je le redis
je rappelle que c'était 65 ans
initialement il y a beaucoup d'ajouts
qui ont été faits sur les carrières
longues en particulier donc cette phase
de concertation et cette modification de
la loi a été faite donc et pour moi
derrière nous et mettons il y a d'autres
sujets qui nous attend dans le parlera
peut-être tout à l'heure mais le partage
de la travail le partage de la valeur
pardon le plein d'employé encore de
nombreux sujets qui nous attendent et
qui seront aussi autant d'objets de
discussion avec des organisations
syndicales alors Charles de Gauchon vous
faites partie vous des contestataires à
sa réforme puisque vous êtes rapporteur
de la proposition de loi qui vise à
l'abroger est-ce que vous soutenez ces
manifestants qui sont dans la rue et
est-ce que c'est pas un baroud d'honneur
finalement aujourd'hui non mais ce qui
est important c'est l'opinion publique
l'opinion publique reste massivement
hostile
à cette réforme et massivement hostile
aussi au fait que les députés n'ont
jamais voté
ni pour ni contre et ça c'est
incompréhensible et c'est à dire qu'on a
tout à la fois une crise démocratique
mais aussi une crise sociale si on
n'avait jamais vu une unité syndicale
durée aussi longtemps 14 manifestations
donc le gouvernement a réussi quand même
un tour je dirais magique quoi réussir à
unifier l'ensemble des syndicats alors
qu'une partie d'entre eux étaient prêts
un vrai dialogue avec le gouvernement et
de l'éradicaliser j’écoutais hier la
position du secrétaire général de la CGC
quand même un syndicat réformiste modéré
extrêmement dur
ce matin j'écoutais le secrétaire
général de la CFTC syndicat très
réformiste très modéré voyez mais vous
avez entendu aussi Laurent Berger qui
dit que finalement la manifestation est
en train de se terminer le match est en
train de d'être fini finalement c'est la
fin de cette séquence retraite
il est extrêmement dur à l'égard du
comportement il y a eu le gouvernement
contrairement à ce que vient de dire mon
collègue rapporteur général du budget il
n'y a eu aucune
concertation au sens vraiment un échange
etc c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
chacun des 5 principaux syndicats de
salariés j'ajoute pour vous faire rire
que les trois syndicats représentatifs
patronaux nous ont dit à peu près la
même chose et que il aspire qu'à une
chose c'est qu'on redonne un vrai
pouvoir de négociation aux partenaires
sociaux qui ont été capables par exemple
sur le partage de la valeur de proposer
une discussion c'est pas du tout le
gouvernement alors là on les a vu quand
même sur lui mais on va devoir de la
scène et moi je suis de ceux qui ont
toujours respecté et encourager la
démocratie sociale vous voyez et donc ce
qui montre que
on aide les partenaires sociaux
éventuellement leur dire mais telle et
telle chose nous on est tout à fait
presque et on discuter
mettez-vous d'accord et après on
pourrait le le s'il y a besoin d'une loi
et bien on le transposera dans la loi on
va revenir justement sur les partenaires
sociaux Sophie Binet genre un
équesteneuve qui dit qu'en fait ce n'est
pas terminé tout ça n'est pas fini elle
n'est pas prête finalement à rendre les
armes est-ce que on peut imaginer qu'il
y ait encore un retrait de cette réforme
ou est-ce que pour vous c'est c'est
terminé
peut-être revenir sur des fondamentaux
on fait pas cette réforme pour se faire
plaisir on fait pas cette réforme pour
qu'il y ait des Français dans la rue on
fait cette réforme parce que nous avons
une obligation financière pour sauver
notre système par répartition il faut
revenir assez fondamentaux et tout ce
que nous faisons depuis c'est justement
pour permettre l'équilibre de notre
système de retraite donc bien sûr notre
position n'a pas changé et nous irons
jusqu'au bout pour que cette réforme
s'applique le plus rapidement possible
c'est pour les Français que nous faisons
ça et donc voilà pour la raison après je
vois pas pourquoi on reviendrait en
arrière est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ce qui vient d'être dit Charles de
Courson vous a vu défendre depuis des
années ici à l'Assemblée nationale la
bonne tenue des finances publiques quand
vous entendez qu'il faut nécessairement
cette réforme pour équilibrer le système
pour sauver notre système par
répartition vous êtes toujours défendu
une réforme des retraites mais pas du
tout comme cela nous avons proposé
d'ailleurs à la première ministre 5
mesures pour encourager nos concitoyens
à travailler plus longtemps ce qui est
déjà le cas d'ailleurs avant même cette
loi puisque les derniers chiffres sont
les suivants là j'effectif de départ à
retrait dans le régime général est déjà
à 63 ans et demi et ça monte très vite
et donc ce qu'il fallait c'était
encouragé ce mouvement et on avait
proposé cinq mesures qui est dans la
contenu aucun ça c'est ma première
observation à dire observation c'est que
nous allons avoir à discuter des comptes
des régimes de base de la protection
sociale où est le très grand déficit il
est sur la branche maladie on est à 21
milliards de déficits en 2022 9% des
dépenses d'assurance maladie vous savez
quel est le montant du déficit sur les
régimes de base retraite on est y
compris FSV à 2 milliard 5 c'est-à-dire
grosso modo un peu moins de 1%. donc il
y avait parfaitement des mesures nous on
en a proposé mais nous on est on met ça
sur la table et après de discuter avec
les parties sociaux et on pouvait
parfaitement arriver un accord
d'ailleurs les partenaires sociaux l'ont
fait avec beaucoup plus de courage
d'ailleurs que les gouvernements
successifs se régiment de base car ils
ont réformé le régime agir Carco
c'est-à-dire les retraites
complémentaires des salariés avec
beaucoup plus de doigtés et
d'intelligence que
ce qu'on fait les gouvernements
successifs donc voilà nous c'était ça
notre orientation alors l'Inter syndical
manifeste on l'a vu dans la rue Elsa
mondingava vous êtes salle des quatre
colonnes alors on sait que la
proposition de loi du groupe sera
débattu jeudi dans l'hémicycle on sait
qu'il y a 299 amendements qui ont été
déposés mais en attendant il faut qu'il
passe sous le tamis de lire cevabilité
oui et ce évidemment Brigitte qui
retiennent toute l'attention ce sont les
amendements qui rétablissent l'article
premier de la proposition de loi c'était
l'article principal pour abroger la
réforme des retraites et revenir à 62
ans un article souvenez-vous supprimé la
semaine dernière lors de la commission
des affaires sociales et donc les
oppositions veulent réintroduire sous
forme donc d'amendements on le sait sur
les amendements la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale Yael Brown privé a
le pouvoir de déclarer les recevabilité
et la présidente de l'Assemblée l'a déjà
dit elle prendra ses responsabilités il
restera alors une décision pour le
groupe liotte ou non l'examen du texte
jeudi matin et le groupe devrait
maintenir l'examen de ce texte ne
serait-ce que pour passer deux heures
pendant ce qu'on appelle la discussion
générale pour dénoncer les joies du
gouvernement et de la majorité et puis
ensuite et bien ça peut être une motion
de censure puisque c'est une option
sérieusement envisagée par les groupes
de laupes et par le groupe yote alors
Charles de Courson est-ce que vous
pensez que cette article 40 va passer
parce que vous avez déposé un amendement
de rétablissement de l'article 1 donc
pour revenir à la retraite à 62 ans
est-ce que vous craignez qu'il y ait une
censure de la Présidence de l'Assemblée
nationale
le craindre bien sûr mais ce que je
crains c'est pas c'est moins pour ce
texte que pour la démocratie française
parce que il faut bien voir que si la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
déclarait non conforme à l'article 40 un
amendement qui ne fait que rétablir un
article qui avait été déclaré conforme
par le Bureau de l'Assemblée nationale
ça serait un précédent historique qui
permettrait à la majorité du moment
quand il y en a une
de dézinguer toutes les propositions de
loi et donc de vider de son contenu l'un
des éléments fondamentaux de la réforme
de la Constitution de 2008 qui justement
a ouvert ses créneau de tir ces
propositions loi notamment pour les
groupes de l'opposition donc si vous
voulez c'est une décision extrêmement
importante qu'elle va devoir prendre et
comme c'est toujours positionnée comme
une grande défendresse des droits du
Parlement nous attendons avec impatience
sa décision Jean René Cazeneuve est-ce
que enfin vous vous n'êtes pas d'accord
évidemment avec Charles de Courson vous
avez rendu des conclusions pour dire que
cet article était irrecevable que cette
proposition de loi était irrecevable
vous souhaitez donc que la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale disent que cette
amendement de rétablissement a été
recevable et elle jugera évidemment mon
sujet est-ce que je suis d'accord ou pas
d'accord je je j'applique le droit pour
juste savoir que sous le monde après ses
dents pour prendre une référence
16000 fois un amendement a été déclaré
et recevable donc c'est une grande
banalité donc si la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale décider avant la
séance que un amendement qui va coûter
au bas mot entre 15 et 17 milliards
horizons 2030 et et pas recevable c'est
vous les c'est comme d'habitude et ça
toujours été fait comme ça donc il n'y a
pas de il n'y aurait pas de nouveautés
moi je voudrais quand même revenir en
une seconde sur ce qu'a dit on chers
collègues de Courson le problème c'est
que on voit bien que cette association
est hétéroclite pour pas être
désagréable qui va de l'extrême gauche à
l'extrême droite en passant par le
groupe yacht ne défend pas le même
projet qui vous disent qu'il y a pas de
problème de déficit il y en a qui vous
disent il y en a qui vous disent qu'il
faut passer à Soissons d'autres qui font
rester à 62 donc il faut aller à 64 oui
il y a pas de contre-projet le seul
projet qui tient la route qui nous
permet de financer c'est c'est le nôtre
donc pour revenir sur l'article 40 il
n'y a pas de doute si vous voulez il n'y
a pas d'exception dans depuis la 5ème
sous la 5e République quand une
proposition de loi dont un article crée
une charge
non discutable de composition sur le
Bien Vieillir qui est côté 7 à 8
milliards qui a bien été discuté dans
les articles de l'Assemblée nationale et
qui a été jugé recevable pour le coup
pourquoi
changer les règles du jeu et je veux
dire pourquoi pas du tout on peut
changer d'arrêt du jeu décidé que
l'article 40 il faut le supprimer que on
bride etc mais ce qui se passe c'est que
aujourd'hui l'article 40 est protecteur
il est protecteur pour nous finances
publiques parce que vous aussi vous
imaginez qu'à chaque fois qu'il y a une
une niche parlementaire tous les mois
les parlementaires y compris de la
majorité d'ailleurs c'est une loi aussi
pour éviter les initiatives des députés
de la majorité également qui est traité
de la mec qui sont traités de la même
manière si à chaque fois chaque niche on
en met pour 15 milliards à quoi
correspond le budget qu'on fait en fin
d'année quelle est la responsabilité du
gouvernement donc il faut et ça arrive
et c'est tant mieux que le gouvernement
c'est ce qu'on a fait pour la PPL
Chassaigne par exemple si le
gouvernement est d'accord lui seul c'est
de son ressort peut lever cette cette
parole dans un tout petit instant
Charles de Courson mais nous sommes avec
Eric Coquerel qui est député la France
insoumise de Seine-Saint-Denis président
de la commission des finances et qui lui
a bien jugé recevable cette proposition
de loyauté à cause de vos côtés Hélène
Bonduelle
[Musique]
exactement Brigitte monsieur Coquerel on
est dans la manifestation mais on sait
que ça joue aussi à l'Assemblée
nationale avec notamment
l'irrésorabilité de ses amendements de
cette proposition de loi Eliott est-ce
que vous craignez que cette proposition
de loi soit vidée de sa substance
j'espère bien que non parce que ça
serait malheureusement une première bien
comprendre une chose c'est que la
pratique constante fait que
on déclare recevable les amendements qui
rétablissent un texte initial qu'il a
été voilà c'est assez simple depuis le
début de la 5e rue on a toujours été
assis donc j'espère bien j'ai bien
entendu que c'était peut-être ce qui
allait faire la présentation mais
j'espère bien qu'elle ne le fera au
final pas et j'espère en plus qu'elle va
me consulter parce que ça c'est une
autre pratique constante que une
présidente de l'Assemblée consulte au
président de la commission des finances
sur les amendements alors si c'était le
cas il y aurait plus beaucoup de moyens
de contrer cette réforme des retraites
est-ce que vous êtes prêt à aller
jusqu'à une motion de censure alors déjà
si c'était le cas il y a des amendements
quand même qui même s'ils sont
symboliques pourront signif la volonté
de l'Assemblée nationale de revenir sur
cette réforme voilà ça serait d'un
signal politique et moi pour ma part oui
je pense qu'il faut une leçon de censure
pourquoi parce que c'est plus seulement
la question des retraites c'est la
question du respect de la démocratie
parlementaire voilà on ne peut pas
appliquer une fois quelque chose et une
autre fois quelques autres choses si
c'est l'opposition qui présente des
propositions de loi et c'est exactement
la jurisprudence qui est en train
d'installer la majorité en déclarant y
recevable cette proposition lot ou en
tout cas son article emblématique alors
même que m'appuyant sur la jurisprudence
et les compensations prévues par cette
réforme par cette loi je l'ai déclaré
rosswagen merci beaucoup monsieur
Coquerel on vous laisse rejoindre à la
manifestation
Charles de Courson vous avez signé une
tribune hier dans le monde où vous
évoquez cette cette jurisprudence
justement sur les propositions de loi ah
non mais ça serait la première fois si
la présence nationale déclarait
irrecevable au regard d'article 40 un
amendement qui vise à rétablir un
article qui a été déclaré recevable par
le Bureau de l'Assemblée nationale ça
serait la première fois dans l'histoire
de la Cinquième République c'est pas du
tout des amendements enfin classique
40 parties 40 parce que ça crée une
charge ou ça diminue la recette sans
compensation etc c'est pas du tout ça
c'est quelque chose beaucoup plus grave
d'ailleurs le Rapporteur général a avoué
son crime
en disant que c'était l'ortie 40 c'est
pas grave s'il y a une proposition de
loi qui d'après lui et contraire à
l'article 40 mais que le gouvernement
est d'accord bon laisse passer mais
c'est très grave de dire cela parce que
ça veut dire que les hommes étaient
quelque part qu'elle creuse un peu le
déficit ah non non mais c'est pas ça le
débat le ça c'est que jamais dans la
Cinquième République un président
d'assemblée nationale n'a sorti
l'article 40 contre un article de
rétablissement d'un dispositif qui avait
été considéré comme receva par le Bureau
de l'Assemblée jamais arrivé jamais
d'ailleurs monsieur le rapporteur
général pouvez-vous me citer un autre
cas et vente antérieures il y en a aucun
je l'ai fait vérifier
du bureau national chers collègues je
vous rappelle à la raison et la
responsabilité systématiquement il y a
eu depuis ce début de mandat assez
intéressant entre 820 et 830 PPL qui ont
été déposés c'est-à-dire lucidence donc
oui que les députés travaillent toutes
toutes sont acceptées toutes sont
déposés ils pas on part du principe
c'est ça la jurisprudence qu'il n'y a
pas de contrôle a priori au moment du
dépôt mais que c'est bien le rôle des
députés qui le souhaitent de déclencher
après une fois que la PPL est à l'ordre
du jour par exemple le fameux article
89 qui permet à n'importe qui de
demander le jugement donc c'est pas
parce que ça a été déposé à la porte
absolument aucune garantie c'est
absolument c'est un gros mensonge alors
on va à présent retrouver je vous donne
la parole après on n'a pas fini le débat
fait bien dit Philippe ok député les
républicains de la Moselle et qui se
trouvent aux côtés de Stéphanie
Despierres celle des quatre colonnes
jeudi c'est la proposition loi liotte
pour abroger la réforme des retraites la
gauche Elliot gris déjà au scandale si
la présidente de l'Assemblée fait jouer
le fameux article 40 est-ce que c'est
aussi votre position il y a deux aspects
sur lesquels Charles de Courson a raison
le premier et bien c'est que la
proposition du gouvernement pouvait
paraître injuste inadapté au défi
démographique auquel on a affaire dans
les années à venir et donc elle est
problématique et le deuxième et bien
c'est le fait qu'elle n'a jamais été
votée par les députés et ce péché
originel il continuera toujours de
l'entacher maintenant en tant que
opposition notre responsabilité ce n'est
pas seulement de balayer d'un revers de
masse qui a été fait on doit être
capable de dire qu'est-ce qu'on propose
pour la suite du système avec une
démographie qui va chuter jusqu'à 1,4
enfin par femme le système par
répartition même à 64 68 ans d'âge légal
reste dramatiquement remise en cause
alors ce que j'aurais aimé c'est que
cette proposition de loi elle dise
clairement quelle alternative les
oppositions proposent parce que si c'est
pour avoir comme le veut la nu que des
taxes supplémentaires et des charges sur
les salaires pour financer les retraites
ce n'est pas la même chose si c'est pour
reculer l'âge légal et assister à une
baisse des pensions alors que beaucoup
de retraités sont déjà dans la
difficulté ce n'est pas la même équation
si on veut rajouter un système et ce
sera inévitable à terme complémentaire
assurantielle au-dessus du système par
répartition et bien là aussi c'est
encore un message différent mais ce que
je veux dire c'est qu'en tout cas on
doit être transparent vis-à-vis des
Français sur les solutions qu'on propose
malheureusement cette proposition de loi
ne l'est pas complètement merci beaucoup
on va retrouver à présent Kevin mauvieux
qui est député rassemblement national de
l'Eure et qui se trouve aussi à votre
micro Stéphanie Despierres Kevin mauvio
alors cette proposition loi de liotte
qui sera débattue ou peut-être pas
débattu jeudi fait beaucoup de débats
quelle est la position du rassemblement
national est-ce que vous aussi vous
criez à une atteinte au droit de
l'opposition bah évidemment
manifestement il y a une attente au
droit de l'opposition de la part de la
majorité quand on nous empêche de voter
sur un texte aussi important une
première fois puis une seconde fois et
puis quand avec une proposition de loi
qui émane dans partie d'opposition on
essaye à travers les articles 40 encore
une fois de museler le Parlement il y a
une atteinte à la liberté d'expression
du Parlement à la prise en compte de la
voix du peuple parce qu'il faut pas
oublier une chose c'est que derrière le
vote des députés on n'est pas frustré
par rapport à nous c'est pas parce qu'on
ne peut pas voter qu'on est frustré on
est frustré parce qu'on représente la
population française on représente le
peuple et quand on voit que le
gouvernement empêche l'expression du
peuple ça nous pose problème une fois
deux fois 11 fois peut-être 12 fois
d'une façon plus indirect que les autres
fois mais ça pose quand même question et
ça pose problème je trouve si les
insoumis déposent une motion de censure
est-ce que le rassemblement national est
prêt à la voter écoutons on en a pas
discuté à ce stade après jusqu'à lors on
a toujours été cohérent on a toujours
été droit dans nos bottes nous notre
objectif c'est de protéger la France et
les Français et ce peu importe d'où
émane les textes les motion de censure
de la France insoumise on en a déjà voté
par le passé
s'il le faut on recommencera nous on
part du principe que défendre les
Français ça dépasse les clivages
politiques ça dépasse les étiquettes
tout le monde ne le pense pas mais c'est
notre doctrine et donc si la seule façon
de faire tomber la réforme des retraites
et si ça peut fonctionner c'est de voter
une motion de censure en fonction de ce
que contient la motion de censure il est
pas impossible qu'on la vote merci
beaucoup
vous avez entendu ce que vient de dire
Kevin mauvieux finalement il y a pas eu
de vote et il y aura peut-être pas de
vote sur les retraites puisque cette
proposition de loi n'est pas sûr d'être
débattue dans son incertie jeudi est-ce
que c'est un problème le collègue des
Philippot est clairement ce que je dis
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
contre-proposition ce qui vont voter
contre aujourd'hui ils défendent des
projets absolument différents qui n'ont
rien à voir les uns entre par rapport
aux autres bien sûr qu'on a voté on a
voté une notion de censure je vous
rappelle suite aux 49-3 ça sert à ça
elle a été enfin
on a voté en commission là aussi 38 voix
à 34 et les commissions sont
parfaitement représentatives du point
des parties politiques donc on a voté
également je vous rappelle que si on n'a
pas voté sur le texte initial c'est
parce que la nupaisse qui sont les
nouveaux amis de de Charles de Courson
la nupesse a fait de l'obstruction
organisée de l'obstruction avec 20000 un
moment parce qu'ils ne voulait pas aller
au vote sur l'article 7 donc c'est
vraiment pas quelque chose donc on peut
nous accuser nous voulons faire
respecter la Constitution est-ce que
vous pensez Charles de Courson que vous
allez retirer votre proposition de loi
si toutefois les recevabilités et
décidés sur sur l'article 1 finalement
ce qui vide de substances votre texte si
vous avez regardé les amendements que
nous avons déposé il n'y a pas
uniquement les amendements de
rétablissement de du texte initial sur
lequel nous espérons bien que la
présidente se gardera l'article 40 mais
dans l'hypothèse où elle le ferait
prenant une très grave responsabilité
sur la suite des opérations je dis une
très grave responsabilité parce que le
Parlement l'Assemblée nationale peut
tout bloquer quand on est une minorité
vous voyez c'est ce qui est déjà arrivé
hier soir et puis ça va continuer vous
voyez
nationale
bloquer oui quand on est majoritaire et
que une minorité veut s'imposer aux
autres ça veut dire quoi vous êtes mis
d'accord avec les oppositions c'est une
alliance des oppositions
la majorité des avais vu dans leur
diversité on peut pas accepter que un
groupe minoritaire veuille imposer sa
volonté contre la majorité des
représentants du peuple français c'est
donc acceptable
ce que vous nous dites
des courants très différents quand aux
propositions je partage ce que disait
monsieur notre collègue dit Philippot
mais nous nous avons proposé à la
première ministre des solutions Donald
tenue aucun compte
je sais pas si les autres groupes ont
fait la même chose
de financement de la référence nous
l'avons fait est-ce que vous
maintiendrez votre texte si toutefois
l'article 1 est jugé et recevable
où est-ce que vous le retirez attendons
attendons
nous réagissons pas par anticipation
en ajustera le tir si je puis dire en
fonction déjà de la position de Madame
le Premier ministre mais je rappelle que
la minorité présidentielle a déposé des
dizaines d'amendements avant l'article
premier pour tout faire aussi pour qu'on
ne vote pas puisque on voit bien que
c'est bien l'intention est depuis
l'origine de cette minorité
présidentielle c'est de tout faire pour
qu'on ne vote pas parce qu'ils savent
qu'ils sont minoritaires c'est ça ce qui
est terrible et ça ça peut pas durer
vous vous voulez un vote s'il n'y a pas
de vote sur cette réforme des retraites
sur votre proposition de loi est-ce que
vous déposerez une motion de censure au
nom du groupe liotte on verra j'ai déjà
répondu à cette question nous verrons et
il y a plusieurs textes d'ici le 21
juillet qui pourrait faire l'objet d'une
motion censure et donc on verra en
fonction mais ne préjugés pas de ce qui
va se passer je dis en séance ce qu'on
entend c'est que l'Assemblée nationale
pourrait être bloquée finalement faute
de majorité trouvable ça vous inquiète
vous pensez que ça va être beaucoup plus
compliqué aujourd'hui qui aura
véritablement un avant et un après
réforme des retraites si je voulais être
réducteur cette la vœu de Charles de
Courson en dit long il y a ceux qui
veulent bloquer notre pays et ceux qui
veulent le faire avancer nous voulons
faire avancer notre pays et régler les
problèmes des Français les uns après les
autres donc si vous voulez nous avons
depuis le début les Français nous ont
donné une majorité relative contact et
donc depuis le début nous avons texte
par texte nous sommes allés chercher des
majorités sur la très grande majorité
des lois sauf sur les lois de
financement sur lesquels nous avons
évidemment sommes passés par le 49.3
c'est une tradition que les oppositions
c'est pénalisant pour nos fonctionnaires
c'est pénalisant pour l'administration
ça fait rigoler l'extrême gauche et
l'extrême droite moi ça ne m'amuse pas
et voilà c'est un exemple de bénéfique
vous pourrez trouver avec la droite des
majorités dans les mois à venir nous
continuerons la première ministre la
montrer et nous chercherons sur nous
chercherons sur chacun des textes des
majorités textes par textes quelquefois
à gauche quelquefois à droite
quelquefois j'espère avec nos collègues
liottes si change de comportement sur ce
sujet là et nous continuons on n'a pas
d'autres solutions que celle-là donc
c'est ce que veulent les Français est-ce
que nous voulons aussi Charles de
Courson vous l'avez écrit aussi dans
votre tribune vous craignez de la
violence de cette colère mais on pousse
on pousse si vous voulez au
désinvestissement démocratique
c'est-à-dire pourquoi moi j'ai des
électeurs qui viennent me voir une
dimension de course ça sert à quoi
d'aller voter au législatives pour lire
des députés puisque un gros trois
groupes minoritaires peuvent imposer à
coups de procédures des textes dont le
peuple français à travers ses
représentants ne veulent pas c'est
extrêmement grave institution vous
remettez la Constitution
47 ans
mais attendez c'est mais vous voulez
parce que
la motion de censure qui est la dernière
arme pour renverser le gouvernement
finira par passer sur un texte ou un
autre ça d'ailleurs après la dernière
fois ne voient prévoir et encore c'est
qu'une motion de censure sur un par
exemple mais bien sûr
ça pourrait passer mais elle peut elle
peut être pas forcément sur ce texte
mais sur d'autres textes sur la loi de
programmation qu'on nous annonce au mois
de juillet oui et il faut arrêter de
considérer qu'on peut imposer sa volonté
quand on est minoritaire ça c'est pas
une attitude démocratique moi je fais
partie de la majorité je fais partie de
l'opposition en 30 ans de vie politique
ça va ça vient comme on dit voilà donc
je connais mais respecter si vous voulez
la démocratie c'est la première fois
depuis 58 qu'il n'y a pas de majorité et
que un président réélu
plus par dépit que par adhésion
aux législatives un mois plus tard ces
soutiens font 25% des 47% qui sont venus
voter vous rendez compte où on en est
donc comment voulez-vous diriger un pays
quand vous faites 12 à 13 % du corps
électoral c'est impossible et donc soit
c'est ce que prétendait certains il y a
un gouvernement de large rassemblement
voilà soit on revient devant le peuple
c'est ça la démocratie mais tout le
monde sait souhaiter une dissolution ah
ben c'est pas moi qui le décide c'est le
président de la République bien sûr mais
mais la minorité présidentielle ne veut
surtout pas dissolution ils sont 2050 et
un je crois ils savent pertinemment qui
reviendront à Sens 150 il y a qu'à
regarder les sondages voyez et donc et
donc c'est ça le grand danger
démocratique pour terminer Jean-René
Cazeneuve est-ce qu'on peut continuer
quatre ans comme ça avec une assemblée
telle qu'on la connaît aujourd'hui avec
ce que ce que vient de dire Charles de
Courson aussi Charles de Courson
que la majorité aurait moins de députés
donc tu aurais plus de députés de
l'extrême droite et plus aidés de
l'extrême gauche et je pense qu'il
formerait un formidable
gouvernement avec peut-être Charles de
Courson ministre des Finances non c'est
une plaisanterie donc si vous voulez
c'est une contrainte je trouve que la
Constitution est très robuste au
contraire et moi je trouve que nos
institutions sont extrêmement fortes
puisqu'elles nous permettent alors que
nous avons une majorité relative elle
nous permet de fonctionner c'est pour ça
qu'elle a été fait le 49-3 pour être
capable de passer des budgets pour tenir
nos engagements c'est pour ça qu'elle a
été fait l'article 40 qui une fois de
plus a été utilisé 16000 fois sous le
mandat précédent pour éviter qu'il y ait
une dérive de nos finances publiques
j’espère qu'au moins cet argument
pourrait sonner juste à l'oreille de de
mon cher collègue de conso mais même pas
donc la Constitution est nous permet de
fonctionner et nous allons exportex
aller chercher des majorités et nous
modifierons le texte comme nous l'avons
fait au coup d'amendement pour aller
chercher ces majorités je trouve ça
c'est une belle méthode et c'est la
nouvelle méthode comme hier comme hier
vous avez été battus
en tout cas et une éventuelle et
responsa et il recevabilité de cette
amendement visant à revenir à la
retraite à 62 ans peut-être dans les
heures qui viennent merci en tout cas à
tous les deux d'être venu débat sur ce
sur ce plateau on passe à présent au
focus dans cette émission
[Musique]
et on va parler des députés écologistes
qui ont annoncé le lancement d'une
commission d'enquêtes parlementaires sur
les dérives des fédérations sportives
les violences sexistes et sexuelles
l'homophobie le racisme et la corruption
après plusieurs scandales qui ont secoué
le mouvement sportif français c'est la
député écologiste des Hauts-de-Seine
Sabrina sebahi qui porte cette
initiative elle est au micro de ses
familles et des pierres bonjour Sabrina
sebahi sur quoi voulez-vous enquêter
précisément bonjour alors on va la
commission d'enquête qu'on propose c'est
sur les dérives dans le mouvement
sportif de manière générale notamment
sur les fédérations sportives puisqu'on
voit bien aujourd'hui qu'on a cite
quasiment quotidiennement à des
scandales qui éclaboussent le monde du
sport mais on parle de quoi de
corruption de violences sexuelles et
sexistes d'homophobie de tout ça ou on
parle de tout ça bien évidemment on
verra bien que ce sont des
dysfonctionnements qui sont structurels
aujourd'hui au sein de ces fédérations
notamment que ce soit sur les VSS ou
violences sexuelles et sexistes sur la
question financière le cet argent qui
transite et cette corruption qui a l'air
quasi permanente au sein de ces
fédérations et bien évidemment le
racisme l'homophobie toutes les
discriminations auxquelles on assiste
comme je vous le disais quasiment
quotidiennement aujourd'hui dans la
presse il y a eu des révélations dans la
presse il y a des enquêtes judiciaires
en cours qu'est-ce que peut apporter de
plus une commission d'enquête par des
députés alors il y a quelques enquêtes
qui sont en cours effectivement mais on
a le sentiment déjà que ces affaires en
fait elles ont commencé il y a très
longtemps que la parole c'est très peu
libéré même si maintenant on le voit de
plus en plus en réalité mais que souvent
c'est très peu suivi en fait d'affaires
judiciaires puisque il n'y a pas de
plantes ou alors on met tout simplement
le coach ou les personnes qui sont
qui sont dans ces affaires-là de côté au
sein des fédérations et des clubs
sportifs sans qu'il est réellement de
sanctions vis-à-vis de ces personnes ni
d'affaires judiciaires donc l'objectif
de cette commission sera d'une part de
créer un cadre pour permettre aux
victimes qui le souhaitent de pouvoir
s'exprimer de libérer cette parole dans
le milieu dans le mouvement sportif et
peut-être d'apporter des éléments de
réponse sur finalement une
transformation du monde sportif est-ce
qu'il y a des sports des fédérations sur
lesquels vous allez vous focaliser plus
précisément
oui alors je pense que on travaillera au
sein de la Commission à cibler certaines
fédérations en particulier celles qui
sont le plus impactées aujourd'hui par
toutes ces par exemple et bien je pense
au foot je pense au tennis je pense bien
enfin voilà il y a la clé il y a
quelques fédérations comme ça ou il y a
de vrais sujets sur lesquels on peut
aller creuser pour justement pouvoir
avancer sur ces questions là et puis
surtout redonner une image très positive
du sport qui est à la base quand même
est un vecteur d'émancipation de notre
jeunesse et là il est vraiment mis à mal
est-ce qu'il faudra créer des mécanismes
pour que les directions de ces
fédérations tournent un peu plus se
renouvelle un peu plus alors il y a une
vraie question sur la question des
dirigeants de ces fédérations parce que
pendant longtemps c'était des anciens
sportifs qui ont été qui ont pris la
tête de ces fédérations on voit une
évolution depuis ces dernières années
avec notamment le milieu politique et le
monde des affaires qui prend la
direction de ces fédérations qui amène
d'autres lots de problématiques
notamment sur la question financière et
on pense effectivement qu'aujourd'hui il
doit avoir un peu plus de transparence
un peu plus de roulement finalement
l'objectif serait de redonner le sport
au bénévole merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous
si vous nous rejoignez sur LCP sachez
que nous sommes à moins d'une demi-heure
des questions au gouvernement que vous
allez pouvoir suivre en direct et en
intégralité sur LCP toujours ici en
direct de la salle des pas perdus au
cœur de l'Assemblée nationale à quelques
mètres de la salle des quatre colonnes
et de l'hémicycle et derrière moi vous
le voyez la garde républicaine qui est
déjà installé et qui jouera du tambour
tout à l'heure à l'arrivée de la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale et
puis une image encore celle-ci celle de
la cathédrale Notre-Dame en maquette qui
est imposée là ici à l'Assemblée pour
monter et bien l'avancée des travaux ici
à Notre-Dame voilà pour cette image ici
celle des pas perdue alors dans cette
émission vous retrouverez bien sûr
Stéphanie Despierre et Elsa mon Agava
qui se trouve salle des quatre colonnes
on retrouvera Marco pommier qui lui est
dans l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
nationale pour le menu des questions au
Gouvernement Hélène Bonduelle elle se
trouve dans la manifestation parisienne
contre la réforme des retraites on la
verra aussi tout à l'heure et puis enfin
à partir de de 14h45 nous vous ferons
vivre l'arrivée de la première ministre
et des membres du gouvernement ce sera
cours d'honneur l'entrée principale du
palais Bourbon pour leur on retrouve
Marco pommier dans les tribunes de
l'assemblée et de l'hémistique de
l'Assemblée nationale Marco est-ce qu'il
y aura des questions retraite
aujourd'hui
oui Brigitte on va bel et bien parler de
la réforme des retraites cet après-midi
dans l'hémicycle plusieurs questions sur
le sujet en cette 14e journée de
mobilisation sociale et à deux jours de
l'examen dans l'hémicycle de la
proposition de loi du groupe liotte
objectif vous l'avez compris abroger le
recul de l'âge légal à 64 ans mais cet
après-midi on parlera beaucoup de
logements aussi et notamment à des
annonces d'Élisabeth borne pour tenter
d'enrayer la crise du secteur prêt à
taux zéro prolongé mes conditions durci
aident à la location un plan accueilli
avec beaucoup de réserves par les
professionnels du logement il n'y a pas
de mesure magique a dit la première
ministre Marco et il y aura également
d'autres thèmes qui seront abordés cet
après-midi
oui Brigitte on parlera aussi du
harcèlement scolaire hier le ministre de
l'éducation nationale a reçu notamment
les parents de l'Insee cet adolescente
de 13 ans qui s'est suicidé le mois
dernier après avoir été victime de
harcèlement scolaire et de
cyber-harcèlement un fléau qui
toucherait entre 800 000 et 1 million
d'élèves chaque année autre sujet
abordés les prix des carburants le
contrôle technique des deux roues ou
encore parcoursup la plateforme
d'admission post-bac actuellement 600
000 candidats ont reçu une réponse
positive à leurs vœux
merci Marco et j'accueille à présent sur
ce plateau Mathieu Lefebvre bonjour et
bienvenue vous êtes député renaissance
du Val-de-Marne et Pierre d'arriville
bonjour bienvenue à vous vous êtes
députés GDR communiste des
Bouches-du-Rhône alors je voudrais
d'abord vous faire réagir à une question
citoyenne vous savez que sur LCP on
donne la question aux citoyens pour
savoir la parole aux citoyen pour savoir
quelle question ils auraient posé s'ils
étaient dans l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
nationale cet après-midi alors là c'est
une question de François qui est
agriculteur dans le Loiret et qui est au
micro de Maïté Frémont
moi je m'appelle donc François je suis
agriculteur dans le Loiret pour les
cultures élevage vache allaitantes j'ai
43 ans installé avec mon épouse et on se
pose la question de plus en plus
à quoi va ressembler notre campagne sans
bovin où va-t-on se fournir en viande ou
va-t-on se fournir en lait que va-t-on
faire de nos campagnes où on peut faire
que de la prairie
Mathieu le fait on voit l'inquiétude là
de François qui est agriculteur dans le
Loiret et aussi après le rapport de la
Cour des comptes qui disait qu'il
fallait réduire le cheptel français tout
cela effectivement interroge beaucoup je
pense que la Cour des comptes aurait
mieux fait de faire un rapport sur
d'autres choses et laisser François et
ses bovins tranquilles François il fait
un métier extrêmement difficile il se
lève tôt le matin et il nourrit les
Français qui ont besoin de viande je
crois qu'on doit laisser François
tranquille si on veut lutter contre les
gaz à effet de serre et on doit le faire
on doit lutter contre les industries
polluantes c'est ce qu'on fait avec la
réindustri verte du pays et c'est lutter
aussi contre les comportements qui sont
pas des comportements vertueux et c'est
ce qu'on fait notamment par exemple avec
le bonus malus auto mais les sons de
grâce François tranquille avec ses
bovins pierre d'arrivée est-ce que
effectivement vous vous êtes d'accord
avec ce rapport de la Cour des comptes
est-ce que pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique ça passe
inévitablement par une réduction des
cheptels
d'abord heureusement que c'est pas la
Cour des comptes qui décide d'un dans ce
pays je suis parfois assez dubitatif
devant un certain nombre de ces de ses
conclusions mais nous fournit aussi des
éléments utiles au débat public bon cela
est Indis sur la question qui nous est
posée je crois que le premier sujet si
on voulait regarder les choses de plus
près c'est le nombre d'importations de
viande que nous avons dans notre pays on
importe massivement de la viande de la
viande bovine on pourrait peut-être
d'abord discuter de cette question là si
on voulait aborder le sujet voilà donc
je pense que la Cour des comptes est-ce
que vous dites mais en tout cas on est
capable on le voit dans notre pays de
produire
certains nombre de produits de qualité
donc il y a un travail qui est engagé
pour cela de la part des agriculteurs
bon voilà je crois que avec les
conclusions telles qu'en tout cas elles
me sont revenues on tape à côté des
problèmes quoi
alors on va à présent passer aux
questions au gouvernement et on va
aborder un sujet sensible qui est le
sujet du harcèlement scolaire qui
revient bien évidemment très fort dans
l'actualité un mois après le suicide de
la petite ligne c'est 13 ans la députée
les républicains des Alpes-Maritimes
Alexandra Martin va interpeller le
gouvernement et elle pose sa question
avant au micro d'Elsa mandingava oui le
harcèlement scolaire qui peut donc
conduire à des drames qu'allez-vous
demander au gouvernement quels sont
selon vous les solutions oui
effectivement le drame de la jeune
Lindsay a ému la France entière tout
comme les trois précédents cas
similaires depuis 2021 le ministre de
l'éducation nationale par le de
responsabilité collective d'échecs
collectifs alors oui il y a un échec
mais c'est d'abord celui de la puissance
publique et donc l'échec du gouvernement
échec parce que aujourd'hui les familles
le crient elles se sentent seules face à
ces drames quand elles alertent parce
que aujourd'hui la loi de prévention et
de contre le harcèlement scolaire la loi
phare est monté en puissance mais force
est de constater qu'elle n'est pas
déployée dans tous les établissements et
ça déjà c'est un échec comment laisser
des élèves de la République seul sans
moyens dans les établissements scolaires
justement et d'après vous puisqu'on
imagine que dans chaque circonscription
ce sont des cas qui peuvent arriver et
ce qu'il faut mieux armer les chefs
d'établissement est-ce que eux ont
parfois la clé pour intervenir ou est-ce
que parfois il ne se rendent pas tout à
fait compte de ce qui peut se passer on
le sait ça se passe notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux ça peut être toute la
journée rendez-vous compte trois élèves
dans chaque classe et aujourd'hui
victime de harcèlement ce sont les
chiffres du ministère de l'Éducation
alors oui il faut que la parole se
libère comme dans les violences
intrafamiliales heureusement les femmes
ont pu libérer leurs paroles il faut que
les élèves et les parents puissent
libérer leurs parents et pour cela il
faut que leurs paroles soient prises au
sérieux d'abord que il y ait de la
considération ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui et ce qui n'est pas encore
le cas aujourd'hui de la part du
ministre papendaye et il faut que il
soit mieux accompagné pour cela enfin
les élèves et les parents pourront dire
ce qu'il se passe et il y a
effectivement une formation à accroître
au niveau des chefs d'établissement et
des enseignants de toute l'équipe
pédagogique merci beaucoup sur cette
question du harcèlement scolaire on
entendra la première ministre on
entendra aussi certainement le ministre
de l'Éducation
Mathieu Lefèvre on a entendu papaine DIY
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
parlait des chèques collectifs là député
les républicains Alexandra Martin parle
d'échec du gouvernement est-ce que vous
prenez une part de responsabilité pour
le gouvernement je pense que c'est un
sujet trop grave pour être livré à
polémique j'attends cette séance de
questions au Gouvernement précisément
pour qu'on ait une unité nationale sur
ce sujet on parle d'un enfant de 13 ans
qui s'est suicidé je crois que on ne
peut pas jeter l'eau propre sur la
communauté éducative si évidemment il y
avait des professeurs ou des personnels
éducatifs qui étaient au courant il
l'aurait évidemment signalé et on doit
également souligner que c'est un drame
pour eux aussi que d'avoir perdu cette
petite fille et dans ce moment là je
pense que toute la représentation
nationale suffisamment de réactions de
la part de l'établissement de la part de
l'ensemble de la de la communauté
éducative en tout cas il y a une enquête
administrative et s'il y a eu des
dysfonctionnements et des mises en cause
elles seront réveillées seront révélés
et toutes les conséquences en sont
tirées mais j'aimerais vraiment qu'on
puisse se rassembler et se réunir tout
bord politique confondu parce que
personne ne peut accepter qu'une enfant
de 13 ans se suicide et personne ne peut
accepter la douleur de ses parents qui
jamais n'aurait dû perdre leur petite
fille est-ce que vous êtes d'accord pour
qu'il y ait une unité collective dans
l'hémicycle et plus largement bien sûr
sur cette question du harcèlement
scolaire ce qui est certain c'est qu'il
faut agir face à ces drames et on voit
bien que
c'est aussi révélateur qu'à ma main
d'une éducation nationale qui qui ne va
pas bien je crois qu'on a besoin de
moyens pour combattre le harcèlement
scolaire il y a besoin d'humains en fait
il y a besoin d'adultes qui soient
disponibles
pour accompagner les élèves dans
son milieu blanc avec des personnes
référentes dans chaque établissement
supplémentaires bien sûr ça va libérer
la parole justement
que j'avais porté avec elle dans
laquelle il y avait cette proposition
d'avoir des référents dans chaque
établissement donc ça ça va dans la
bonne direction et nous parlons il y a
pas peine qui arrive justement à
l'Assemblée nationale joue l'exterminer
votre propos
avec la médecine scolaire on manque
d'infirmières scolaire on voit bien
qu'il y a un problème avec les
psychologues scolaires on manque de
psychologues scolaire tout ça c'est
aussi tout un environnement auquel on
doit prendre beaucoup de soins parce que
il y en a besoin tout simplement pour
accompagner les élèves dans leur vie
Mathieu Lefebvre on a aussi renforcé les
moyens pour les cyber-harceleur vous
pensez que c'est complémentaire
effectivement du référent qui peut être
mis dans l'établissement scolaire oui
c'est toute une chaîne qu'il faut
développer un ensemble de moyens qu'il
faut renforcer mais il faut aussi
dénoncer le rôle des réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui en toute impunité on peut
lyncher des élèves sous couvert d'un
anonymat qui est absolument
insupportable y compris d'ailleurs après
la mort de cette pauvre enfant on voit
qu'il y a encore des vidéos qui
circulent il faut que ces vidéos soient
supprimées le plus rapidement possible
et que les réseaux sociaux soient
traduits devant la justice le plus
rapidement possible on ne peut pas se
contenter de dire que c'est la faute et
la responsabilité des personnalités qui
n'auraient pas agi peut-être et on verra
ce que dira l'enquête administrative
mais vraiment les réseaux sociaux et
cette impunité derrière l'anonymat des
réseaux sociaux doit être mise à jour
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord pierre
d'arriville pour dire que c'est l'enfant
harceleur qui doit changer d'école on a
vu le sujet qui s'est posé récemment pas
Penda entendu se prononcer sur le cas
d'un enfant qui est resté chez lui
plusieurs mois parce que justement il y
avait un problème de harcèlement
scolaire dans les petits villages il y a
pas toujours deux écoles c'est pas
toujours facile de pouvoir trouver un
autre établissement c'est quand même
l'enfant harceleur qui doit quitter
l'établissement je crois que ça peut
être effectivement une décision à
prendre le cas échéant mais il faut
évaluer les situations je pense au cas
par cas il faut que la communauté
éducative se saisisse des des questions
posées le plus tôt possible et qu'elle
essaye de de faire en sorte que d'abord
les problèmes se règle entre les enfants
et que on mette fin aux situations de
harcèlement le plus vite possible et
donc ça moi je crois que la communauté
éducative doit pouvoir prendre la main
et prendre les meilleures décisions au
regard de la situation qu'elle connaît
qu'elle décrit etc c'est de ça dans dont
nous avons besoin je pense que
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'il faisait de
faire au quotidien en réalité
alors cet après-midi dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale on va aussi parler
des retraites vous le savez depuis
plusieurs semaines déjà cette question
revient à l'ordre du jour il y a eu 14e
manifestation aujourd'hui qui est parti
à 14h des Invalides en tout cas pour le
cortège parisien direction Place
d'Italie et donc et bien il y a aussi
dans deux jours la proposition de loi du
groupe lyode qui devrait être débattue
ici dans l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
nationale alors évidemment le groupe
liotte revient à la charge cet
après-midi et c'est le président
Bertrand pencher qui compte interpeller
le gouvernement sur ses retraites et il
est à vos côtés Stéphanie Despierre
Bertrand pencher calez vous demander au
gouvernement cet après-midi je vais
demander à la première ministre si elle
a envie ou pas d'apaiser le pays en nous
permettant de voter notre proposition de
loi
et si elle a conscience de la grave
crise institutionnelle qu'elle est en
train de déclencher
si on nous empêche de voter la loi ça
voudra dire que depuis le début de la
cinquième République
on
interdit à des parlementaires quels
qu'ils soient de voter une loi parce que
cette loi des incidences financières ça
voudrait dire que demain
on pourrait plus déposer la plupart des
des lois mais le parlementaire le
gouvernement et les députés de la
majorité Renaissance affirme que ils
veulent le respect de la Constitution et
c'est pour ça qu'il y a ce doute sur la
recevabilité de votre proposition de loi
ou des amendements qui qui
l'accompagnent je crois qu'ils prennent
tout le monde pour des imbéciles ou bien
ils savent pas ce qu'ils racontent ce
qui est grave ou bien ils savent ce
qu'il raconte et c'est encore plus grave
quoi je rappelle que jamais jamais
depuis le début de la 5ème République on
a bloqué une proposition de loi
d'origine parlementaire
en brandissant cette cet article 40 mais
des amendements ont été bloqués
non mais des amendements oui mais pas
des propositions de loi pas des
propositions de loi donc nous nous
rétablissons notre proposition de loi
est-ce que lui ou non on va consacrer le
sabordage de cette assemblée c'est
particulièrement grave et bien merci à
monsieur pencharge je vous laisse
rejoindre l'hémicycle pour aller voir
poser votre question à la première
ministre
Matthieu Lefebvre Bertrand pencher parle
d'une grave crise institutionnelle parce
que vous êtes en train de créer un
précédent sur une proposition de loi en
décidant probablement que cette
proposition de loi finalement a été
recevable est-ce que c'est le même
monsieur pencher ou son hologramme qui
proposait la retraite à 64 ans et
quelques années c'est une question que
je lui pose il est incapable d'y
répondre et deuxièmement monsieur
pencher il est pardon de le dire mais
plus du tout du côté du droit et de la
Constitution puisqu'il nous dit
aujourd'hui que le Conseil
constitutionnel doit être remis en cause
que l'indépendance de ce qu'on appelle
les sages ne vont pas indépendance cela
n'est pas très sérieux ça ressemble à
une tartufferie et je crois que Monsieur
pencher aujourd'hui a enfanté quelque
part un monstre étant la main aux deux
extrêmes il tend la main Marine Le Pen
il tend la main à Mathilde le panneau
sans qu'il n'ait besoin de se la donner
et ça c'est extrêmement dangereux pour
notre démocratie et plus largement ceux
qui pensent que cette réforme pourra
être abrogée auquel ne sera pas mise en
oeuvre seront des bonimenteurs je crois
qu'il faut le dire et le redire aux
Français alors il y a un désaccord de
fond vous avez le groupe communiste
cossigné une tribune hier rédigée par
Charles de Courson dans le monde ou
justement on lit qu'il y a une
jurisprudence sur ces propositions de
loi et que elles sont très souvent
coûteuses et pas nécessairement jugé et
recevable oui bien sûr avant peut-être
de répondre à un instant à votre
question je voudrais dire que évidemment
je ne peux pas laisser Mathieu Lefebvre
d'écrire le paysage politique comme il a
fait en renvoyant tout ce qui n'est pas
lui tout ce qui n'est pas renaissance du
côté de je ne sais quelle extrémisme
d'ailleurs l'extrême droite on connaît
on sait quelle est cette famille
politique elle est effectivement
présente dans l'hémicycle mais extrême
dot elle est extrême gauche à ma
connaissance ça n'est pas le cas nous
sommes la gauche avec la Nupe dans notre
diversité et je crois qu'il faut
respecter ça ne vous déplace pour ce qui
est effectivement de cette proposition
de loi la manière dont la majorité
demande à corps et acry de ne pas
pouvoir voter de d'être empêché de
légiférer finalement c'est très
problématique parce que c'est un
abaissement du Parlement nous devons
pouvoir décider nous devons pouvoir
proposer des lois si nous sommes empêché
de le faire effectivement je crois que
ça va devenir un problème
institutionnel grave lorsqu'il est en
train de se passer c'est que avec
l'article 40 appliqué à l'ensemble des
propositions de loi nous allons être
fortement limité dans notre capacité de
proposition parlementaire je crois que
c'est pas une bonne nouvelle c'est pas
une bonne nouvelle finalement quelle que
soit son camp politique donc je crois
que c'est effectivement très inquiétant
le déséquilibre qui est en train de
s'installer dans la rue qui était déjà
là mais qui est en train de s'aggraver
en tout cas dans nos institutions
l'article 40 là pourrait être décidé sur
un amendement donc ça c'est le pouvoir
de la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale pourtant la sentait pas très
allante pour juger et recevable ce texte
est-ce que le gouvernement lui a tordue
le bras je crois que personne ne peut
tendre le bras d'une présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale la présidente elle
est indépendante mais il faut bien faire
comprendre aux Français que si Monsieur
dareville demain il va augmenter les
dépenses de 20000 euros dans le budget
de l'État il ne peut pas il est censuré
au titre de l'article 40 de la
Constitution et là on pourrait sans
difficulté proposer la retraite à 62 ans
à 15 milliards d'euros donc ça ne pose
aucun problème tout cela est évidemment
faux et le seul projet de Monsieur
pencher le projet alternatif c'est
d'augmenter le prix du tabac il propose
finalement le prix de la cigarette à 20
euros pour financer le déficit de nos
systèmes de retraite cela n'est pas très
sérieux ça veut dire qu'il faut
s'attendre à ce que la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale jugeait recevable
cette amendement de rétablissement de
l'article 1 elle est indépendante donc
elle décidera par elle-même en tout cas
ça moi je le souhaite en tout cas
conforme à toute la jurisprudence du
droit sur la 5e République comme l'a
expliqué genre René Cazeneuve à votre
micro tout à l'heure alors dans ce cas
où effectivement ce serait jugé
irrecevable votre proposition de loi
enfin celle que vous soutenez
effectivement ce serait complètement
vidé de sa substance est-ce que ça vaut
le coup d'aller la défendre dans
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
on va jusqu'au bout croire que
l'Assemblée nationale peut délibérer et
qu'elle peut se prononcer puisqu'elle a
été élue pour ça et donc c'est un usage
que les propositions de loi puissent
être débattues quand même dans dans
cette dans cet assemblée donc j'espère
que ça sera le cas si effectivement nous
sommes empêchés d'examiner ce qui est le
cœur de cette proposition c'est à dire
de la loi mais je crois que ça se
manifestera dans l'hémicycle que
finalement les masques tomberont et on
verra qui est d'accord pour
effectivement
une sanction démocratique que nous
l'Assemblée nationale puisse se
prononcer effectivement sur sur cette
question qui est une question centrale
qui est celle du report de l'âge de
départ voilà si c'était pas le cas
est-ce qu'il faudrait déposer une motion
de censure est-ce que vous pourriez vous
y associer on verra si quelque chose qui
est en discussion et le moment venu au
sein de la nuque ou entre vous plutôt
des discussions ça vous aura pas échappé
autour de cette question là mais il est
évident que bon ça ne suffira pas cette
motion de censure à
ça ne sera pas l'équivalent en réalité
de d'un vote de l'Assemblée nationale
sur sur la proposition de loi ce que
nous souhaitons c'est vraiment que
l'Assemblée nationale puisse se
prononcer et vous battu le fait vous
avez peur du vote de rien du tout et
d'abord il y a eu un vote la semaine
passée il y a eu une majorité en
commission des affaires sociales pour
rejeter l'abrogation du report de l'âge
légal à retraite il à deux catégories de
députés les députés en commission et les
députés en séance League donc il y a
bien eu un vote mais j'observe que du
côté des oppositions il y a peut-être
une majorité de rejets mais il y a
aucunement une majorité de projets
j'entends que les mots d'abrogation de
censure mais que propose-t-il la
retraite à 60 ans à finançable ou
l'absence de solutions et de
propositions du côté du rassemblement
national on voit bien que la seule force
de proposition c'est la majorité
parlementaire merci à tous les deux en
tout cas d'être venu débattre sur ce
plateau à suivre évidemment sur LCP des
jeux 10 cette proposition de loi du
groupe lot pour le on sait que et bien
les manifestants contre la réforme des
retraites sont à nouveau dans la rue
pour une 14ème journée de manifestation
où on attend entre 400 000 et 600 000
personnes Hélène Bonduelle vous vous
êtes dans le cortège parisien
exactement là on est au cœur de la
manifestation vous le voyez autour de
moi c'est très compact le caritate est
passé à quelques instants devant nous
c'est un peu clairsemé au départ mais là
il y a de plus en plus de monde une
ambiance plutôt bonne enfance je dois
dire pour le moment même s'il y a
beaucoup de force de l'ordre parce qu'on
savait le cortège doit passer devant le
restaurant La Rotonde tout un symbole
devient beaucoup de force de l'ordre et
lorsqu'on voit sur les pancartes
évidemment il y a beaucoup de nom à
cette réforme des retraites mais ce qui
revient beaucoup aussi c'est le déni
démocratie le manque de dialogue avec le
gouvernement se croyait un petit peu
moins peut-être dans les précédentes
manifestations alors on verra arriver
Place d'Italie en fin d'après-midi s'il
y a une très forte mobilisation
merci Hélène Bonduelle donc au coeur de
la manifestation parisienne contre cette
réforme des retraites 14e journée de
manifestations les retraites il en sera
aussi question cet après-midi elles a
mon Agava vous vous êtes seul des quatre
colonnes il y a beaucoup d'ambiance de
votre côté écoutez Brigitte je vais être
honnête il y a plus de journalistes dans
cette salle des quatre colonnes que de
députés les derniers députés sont en
train de rentrer dans l'hémicycle pour
ne pas louper le début de la séance des
questions au gouvernement mais
effectivement vous en avez parlé Hélène
en a parlé aussi au coeur du cortège il
sera question des retraites de la
proposition de loi liotte puisque le
président du groupe va interroger la
première Mini sur les jours à venir une
séance donc qui sera peut-être un petit
peu moins calme de ce qui se passe ici
au 4 colonnes pour l'instant
oui cette séance de questions au
gouvernement va évidemment parler des
retraites avec pas moins de deux
questions qui sont posées cet après-midi
on va parler également du logement on va
parler du harcèlement scolaire après le
suicide de la petite Lindsay 13 ans
c'était il y a un mois qui a créé
beaucoup des mois évidemment dans la
communauté éducative les parents de
l'Insee ont été reçus hier par le
ministre de l'éducation nationale pas
peine alors nous ici Salle des pas
perdue je peux vous dire qu'il y a
beaucoup de monde pas beaucoup de
journalistes Elsa mais beaucoup de monde
comme vous allez le voir sur sur ces
images beaucoup de personnes qui sont
venues effectivement voir se cérémonial
ici salle des pas perdus c'est l'arrivée
de la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale alors je vais vous montrer la
présidente de l'Assemblée va arriver par
la porte qui se trouve tout au fond de
cette salle des pas perdus elle arrive
de ses appartements personnels de
l'hôtel de lacets et elle traverse donc
cette salle des pas perdue sous les
tambours de la Garde Républicaine vous
allez les entendre dans quelques
instants et vont retentir pour annoncer
l'arrivée de Yaël Braun Pivet pour cette
séance de questions au gouvernement qui
va démarrer un tout petit peu après 15
heures
[Musique]
et vous venez de voiriel brune Pivet la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
passez donc la salle des séances elle
rentre dans l'hémicycle elle va monter
au perchoir pour présider cette séance
de questions au gouvernement même moment
vous avez vu tout à l'heure arriver
Elisabeth band par l'entrée principale
du palais Bourbon très bonne séance à
tous on se retrouve juste après